to eight in the paint yeah so i said the  beat down  got some courtside spillage  needed mopping up  oh could we have some more spillage no  i think that was the thing i missed most  about not having fans you know the  courtside spillage that was  i miss seeing everyone have to run quick  you're concerning me right now no you  don't love when you see a big diet coco  flying in the air oh this actually may  be something different  let's see  is the fan going to be escorted out here  oh this may be  something more than a spilled drink  look like the fan might have touched  rondo see what happened with rondo and  the fan  what is that guy are you kidding me  [Applause]  so this was not  any sort of  spilled liquid this was